hallo
Luca ist 21 studiert Jura und hat Angst
um seine Zukunft Angst dass sich
Georgien weg von Europa und hin zu
Russland bewegt deshalb kämpft er mit
seiner Protestgruppe für die Absetzung
der georgischen Regierung
glauben dass unsere Regierung pro
russisch ist sie wird von Russland
unterstützt und kontrolliert
die junge Generation Georgiens wirft
ihrer Regierung vor zum russischen
Marionettenregime zu werden vor allem
seit dem Einmarsch Russlands in die
Ukraine
wir können nicht unsere Augen davor
verschließen wie es in Russland ist
starke Korruption die Gerichte sind
nicht unabhängig Menschenrechte werden
nicht geschützt das wollen wir hier
nicht stattdessen wollen wir dir EU
beitreten das wird uns auch für einen
russischen Angriff schützen
seiner Studentengruppe sie planen den
nächsten Protest wollen sich nicht
einschüchtern lassen
[Musik]
Protesten Georgien kann gefährlich sein
einige von ihnen müssen vor Gericht weil
sie gegen die Regierung demonstriert
haben ihre Forderungen schreiben Sie auf
Plakate haltet eure schmutzigen Hände
von georgischen Studierenden fern
den letzten Protesten wurde die
Regierung uns gegenüber aggressiv
trotzdem werden wir uns morgen einem
Studentenprotest anschließen
[Musik]
Luca hofft dass sie das Feuer der Demos
erhalten die angespannte Ruhe nicht mehr
als eine Atempause ist
denn vor zwei Wochen sind tagelang
Tausende auf die Straße gegangen gegen
ein Gesetz das Organisationen und Medien
als ausländische Agenten gebrandmarkt
hätte wenn sie Geld aus dem Ausland
bekommen in Russland wird ein solches
Gesetz zur Verfolgung von Kritikern
genutzt
Georgiens Entscheider überrascht von der
Wucht der Straße reagierten mit
Tränengas und Wasserwerfern
im Parlament Tumulte bevor das Gesetz
erstmal zurückgezogen wurde
wir sind bei der ersten Sitzung nach den
Massenprotesten im georgischen Parlament
der Chef der Regierungspartei ist das
Feindbild der jungen Demonstranten er
hatte sie als Faschisten beschimpft
Rhetorik die an russische Propaganda
erinnert ausgerechnet von einem Jungen
Georgier der in Deutschland studiert hat
im Gespräch mit uns weicht er aus
wir dürfen eine pragmatische Politik
durch eine Nachricht zu erhalten das ist
unser Ziel speziell auf Putin und auf
Russland möchten Sie nicht eingehen also
die unsere zwei historische Regionen
sind von Russland besetzt wir haben
keine diplomatische Beziehungen mit
Russland das ist die heutige Lage mit
Russland aber Frieden auch das zu
erhalten das ist auch unser Ziel
deswegen sollen wir eine pragmatische
Politik durchführen
pragmatische Politik das ist in Wahrheit
ein Schlingerkurs zwischen EU und
Russland der aus Sicht der Kritiker
verschleiern soll dass die Regierung an
Putins Seite steht
Georgien trägt Sanktionen gegen Russland
nicht mit wirft ausgerechnet der Ukraine
vor den Krieg nicht vermieden zu haben
und dem Westen Georgien in den Krieg
hineinziehen zu wollen
im Hintergrund sieht er die Fäden der
Milliardär ivani schwieli Gründer der
Regierungspartei georgischer Traum er
hat sein Vermögen in Russland gemacht
der Vorwurf Erfolge Anweisungen aus
Moskau
Korruption und Abhängigkeit von
russischem Geld für die EU grund genug
erstmal keinen Beitritt in Aussicht zu
stellen
Georgien bekommt seit Jahrzehnten zu
spüren das Russland ist als seine
Einflusssphäre betrachtet wir fahren
nach Westen vor Bayern südostizien die
abtrünnige Provinz wird von Moskau
militärisch kontrolliert
wenige Kilometer später erreichen wir
die Geburtsstadt Stalins in Gori wird
der sowjetische Diktator mit einem
Museum geehrt
Valerie Sushi willi ist Professor ein
Gori und in den 30er Jahren geboren er
sei zwar gegen den Krieg aber wie so
viele seiner Generation trauert er der
Sowjetunion hinterher in der ein
Diktator für Stabilität und Frieden
gesorgt habe
[Musik]
waren die Menschen wirklich vereint
heutzutage sind wir sogar innerhalb des
Landes Feinde damals war das soziale
Umfeld viel besser niemand hätte gesagt
du bist südussete Russe oder Georgia
kein Wort zu den Millionen Toten die
Stalin zu verantworten hat
Putin wolle dem Diktator nacheifern
meint Valerie ein von Russland
dominiertes Großreich wieder aufleben
lassen
Russland ist unser Nachbar vor dem man
nicht weglaufen kann
auch wenn wir die politische Situation
außer Acht lassen es geht um unsere
Handelsbeziehungen
unsere Wirtschaft und unser Handel sind
sehr abhängig von Russland
doch valerie ist Meinung ist selbst hier
in Stalins Geburtsstadt die Ausnahme auf
den Straßen guris fast niemand der die
russlandfreundliche Politik der eigenen
Regierung noch für gerechtfertigt hält
alles in der Welt sollte man eine
Beziehung zu Russland wollen Russland
ist ein besatzerstaat terroristisch und
kriminell
zurück in Tiflis der Tag der Demo viele
sind nicht gekommen weil die ganz große
Wut verflogen ist der dauerprotest ist
auch teuer die meisten Studierenden
müssen nebenbei arbeiten die Jobs sind
schlecht bezahlt
wir sollten bedenken dass die
Studierenden in Georgien in einer
schwierigen Situation sind viele können
es sich nicht leisten ihren Job zu
verlieren und hierher zu kommen
aber heute waren es 100 morgen können es
200 300 sein und so weiter
Luca und seine Freunde sehen eine
demokratische Zukunft für Georgien nur
in der EU und in einem klaren Nein zu
Putins Russland
[Musik]